الآن روبن رايت
كاتب مساهم في مجلة نيويوركر وزميل في
مركز وودرو ويلسون الدولي للباحثين، وهي تنضم إلي الآن
من واشنطن العاصمة، يسعدني رؤيتك
مرة أخرى يا روبن، أعني هناك،
فلنبدأ بالصورة الكبيرة، هناك
هذه الاشتباكات  على الحدود الشمالية
مع لبنان أه الولايات المتحدة تزيد من
تمركز قوتها في المنطقة إيران تحذر
من انتشار إقليمي أم تعلمون أن إيران لديها
مصلحة خاصة في اللعبة الدعائية
ولكن ما هي خطورة تحول كل هذا
إلى
صراع إقليمي هناك  خطر حقيقي للغاية
وهذا ينعكس في نوع اللغة التي
رأيتها من البيت الأبيض ووزارة
الخارجية والبنتاغون خلال
اليومين الماضيين، كما يظهر نشر
مجموعتين قتاليتين من حاملات الطائرات في
شرق البحر الأبيض المتوسط ​​أن
الولايات المتحدة مستعدة لذلك.  لاستعراض
عضلاتها لإظهار أو الإشارة إلى أنها
مستعدة للعمل في حالة نشوب
حرب أوسع في الوقت الحالي، نوع التوترات التي
تحدث بين
وكلاء إيران في الاستهداف سواء كانت تطلق
أه طائرات بدون طيار وصواريخ على إسرائيل من
اليمن أه  إطلاق النار على انتشارين أمريكيين أه
في شرق سوريا انتشار في
مكانين في شمال العراق حيث
تتمركز القوات الأمريكية أه
وطبعا ما يحدث على
الحدود الشمالية لإسرائيل مع أه هجمات
من أكبر وكيل لإيران حزب الله لذلك
هناك  الخطر الحقيقي هو أن إيران لا تقوم
بالتحقيق فحسب، بل تبحث عن شيء
أكبر، ولكن مرة أخرى نحن على هذا النوع من
الهاوية لشيء أكبر،
ولم نصل إلى هناك بعد، وأعتقد أن نوع
الدبلوماسية التي نشهدها تحاول
منع ذلك، نعم  نقطة جيدة أردت
أن أسألك أيضًا لقد قُتل ما يقرب من 100 فلسطيني
في الضفة الغربية المحتلة
أه منذ أن بدأ هذا وتم اعتقال عشرات آخرين
في الغارات الإسرائيلية هل
مخاطر التصعيد في الضفة الغربية تزيد من
القدس الشرقية وماذا سيفعل ذلك لهذا
الصراع تمامًا  المشاعر والغضب
أه بين جميع الأطراف يتزايد
يوما بعد يوم والخطر الحقيقي هو
أن ينقلب الفلسطينيون في الضفة
على حكومة السلطة الفلسطينية
وأنه في عملية
مواجهة أه حماس وغزة
يفقد الإسرائيليون أيضا الخيار  من التحدث
أه إلى القيادة في الضفة الغربية
لأنهم أصبحوا
لا يتمتعون بشعبية متزايدة أه في الداخل لذلك هناك
تداعيات لكل هذا
أه محليًا
وإقليميًا أه يمكن لإسرائيل أن
تعلم أنها استراتيجية قصيرة المدى
أعتقد في غزة تكون ناجحة على المدى الطويل
بدون مسار سياسي
للفلسطينيين، طريق لمستوى معين من
الحكم الذاتي لتقرير المصير، بدون ذلك
لن تكون حماس التالية قاب
قوسين أو أدنى إذا تم القضاء على هذه الحركة كما
وعدت إسرائيل مايكل بأن هذا هو
الحد الأدنى الأكثر أهمية في هذا الصراع
وذلك  هل يمكن لإسرائيل بالتأكيد تحقيق
تقدم عسكري في القضاء على
ترسانات مراكز القيادة والقيادة
ولكن السؤال هو من يحكم حماس أه ماذا
سيحدث بعد ذلك وكيف تمنع
إنشاء مجموعة مسلحة أخرى
ليس على الفور ولكن في المستقبل
لأنه لا توجد
بدائل سياسية  الحروب لا تنتهي عسكريًا
على الإطلاق، هناك دائمًا نتيجة سياسية،
وهذا صحيح بالنسبة لأي حرب كبرى
تنتهي بخلاف ذلك، فالحروب ببساطة تولد المزيد من
الحروب.